the republican-led Senate first vote to
repeal and replace the Affordable Care
Act suffered a bipartisan review late
last night nine Republicans joined every
Democrat to vote down that plan this
came just hours after Senator John
McCain's dramatic return to the chamber
[Applause]
McCain received a standing ovation
yesterday from his Senate colleagues
this was the Senators first time back
since being diagnosed with brain cancer
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
big challenges facing the Republican
effort to overturn Obamacare Nancy good
morning sure was good to see John McCain
yesterday it really was but then that
big setback for Republicans just a
couple of hours later and what that vote
shows is that whatever Republicans end
up with at the conclusion of this day's
long process it is unlikely to be a full
replacement plan for Obamacare this was
the latest replacement plan they've got
and it saw defections from moderates
from conservatives and some centrists
the motion is not agreed to the setback
came just hours after a Senate narrowly
voted to begin debate even then it took
John McCain arriving from Arizona to put
Republicans over the top mr. McCain
Senator McCain newly diagnosed with
cancer then berated the body he has
served in for 30 years
we're getting nothing done my friends
we're getting nothing done he made it
clear that while he voted to start
debate on the GOP plan he is no fan of
the plan itself I will not vote for this
bill as it is today it's a shell of a
bill right now we all know that McCain
said the problem lies with the way the
bill was constructed behind closed doors
bringing it on skeptical members trying
to convince them that it's better than
nothing that it's better than nothing I
don't think that's gonna work in the end
and probably shouldn't
protesters across the capital agreed
McCain urged his colleagues to return to
the Senate's roots and compromise let's
trust each other let's return to regular
order
we've been spinning our wheels on too
many important issues because we keep
trying to find a way to win without help
from across the aisle his colleagues
applauded him John McCain's my hero even
as they prepare let's repeal Obamacare
let's lower premiums for the intensely
partisan battle to come
McCain says he's going to be returning
to Phoenix in a few days to begin cancer
treatment but he joked that he will be
back Charlie to make all his colleagues
regret the nice things they've been
saying about John McCain has both
Republicans and Democrats well wishes as
he goes back for this medical treatment
the question is for me and I think
America what next where are we what's
going to happen well this process that
Republicans are using allows for
unlimited amendments from the right and
the left so this is really a series of
votes perhaps hundreds of votes on
amendments that could take several days
and there's no guarantee that it will
result in anything there you have a you
have a lot of Republicans charlie who
have said that they're very skeptical
about anything that their party has put
forward so far so it's it's quite
possible that they'll vote no at the end
of the day and Republicans will have to
go back to the drawing board maybe even
with Democrats Thank You Nancy